Let us be given a circle and
its diameter.
Let me draw my best diameter.
This is fairly good.
Here is the diameter of the circle.
It's a diameter.
Let's have a triangle for which the diameter is one side,
and the tip of the corner opposite to it
lies somewhere in the circle.
Let's say the angle against this diameter
lies on this circle.
Therefore the triangle looks like this.
The triangle looks like this.
What I will show you in this video is that
this triangle will be a rectangular triangle.
The angle of 90 degrees will be the angle that is
opposed to this diameter.
I do not want to name it yet because it would
the pleasure of proof has failed.
Now let's see what we can do to show that.
In our toolkit we have the idea of ​​an entered angle,
and its connection to the center angle, which
cuts the same arc.
Let's look at this.
Let's say this is an entry corner here.
Let us denote it with the (theta).
Now let's say this is the center of
my circle here.
Then this angle would be a central angle here.
Let me draw another corner here,
another section here.
This is a central corner here.
This is a radius.
It's the same radius - actually that
distance is the same.
But we learned in a previous video that ...
see this inscribed corner, he cuts that arc up here.
The central corner, which cuts the same arc,
is twice that angle.
We have proven it in a previous video.
So it will be 2h.
This is the central angle that cuts the same arc.
Now this triangle here, here,
is an isosceles triangle.
I can rotate it and draw it like that.
If I turned it, it would look like this and then
the green side will be down here.
Both these countries are of length r.
This tip angle is 2 theta.
All I did was turn it around
it looks like this.
This country is here.
Once its two sides are equal, it is an isosceles triangle, therefore
the angles at the base must be equal.
These angles should be the same, or if I had to draw them up here,
this and this should be exactly the same angles at the base.
Now let me see, I already used theta, maybe
I will use x for these angles.
Therefore, this should be x, and that should be x.
How short will it be?
x plus x plus 20 should be 180 degrees.
They are all in a triangle.
Let me write it down.
We have x + x + 2θ = 180 degrees,
or we have 2x + 2θ = 180 degrees,
or we get 2x = 180 - 20.
We divide the two sides of 2 and get x = 90 - θ.
So x = 90 - θ.
Now let's see what else we can do about it.
We can look at this triangle here.
This triangle, this country here, also has this distance
this here is also the radius of the circle.
That distance we have already noted,
is the radius of the circle.
Once again, this is also an isosceles triangle.
These two sides are equal, so these two corners in the base
must be equal.
If this is theta, it will also be
equal to theta.
And in fact we use this information to
we show that the first result for the entered corners and
the relationship between them and the central corners they cut
the same arc.
So if this is theta, it's the theta because it is
isosceles triangle.
So how much is this entire angle here?
Will be θ + (90 - θ).
This angle will be here
θ + 90 - θ.
Well, the teeth are getting shorter.
So whatever, while one side of my triangle is
diameter and then the tip of the opposite corner,
which is opposed to that country,
lies on the circle, then this angle will be here
right angle and it will be a rectangular triangle.
So if I draw something random, like this ...
if it just takes a point here, so, and
I draw it right, it's a right angle.
If I draw something like this and come out that way,
this is a right angle.
For each of these I can do exactly the same proof.
And in fact, the way I drew it here I kept it
basically so that it can be applied to each of these triangles.